going to start this news out with
reports of a mass shooting in the United
States the Los Angeles Times is
reporting multiple casualties at
Monterey Park in California the shooting
began around 10 pm local time near the
site of a Lunar New Year celebration Rob
Reynolds is live for us on the phone
from Los Angeles Rob uh what more do we
know obviously we're in the early stages
of what has been happening
Rob there's very little official
information uh on social media or any
official statements being given by
police or other officials but there are
multiple reports from Monterey Park that
a number of people have been shot and
killed in an incident that happened uh
in the in the late evening
it is not entirely clear where this
happened some Reports say that there was
some witnesses said that the shooting
broke out at a dance club in Monterey
Park others are are unclear but it is on
the first night of the Lunar New Year uh
festival and there were thousands of
people in that area of that City who are
celebrating the Lunar New Year Monterey
Park is a small City have about 60 000
people of a large proportion of them are
of uh Asian American or Pacific Islander
Heritage and it's about uh 11 kilometers
from the center of Los Angeles the Los
Angeles uh County Sheriff's department
and the local police agencies from that
City and neighboring towns are assisting
we're seeing pictures on social media of
wounded people being helped and treated
and put into ambulances by First
Responders and fire department uh
Personnel
some of the reports from eyewitnesses
and I would caution again that as you
said this is an ER at the early stage of
this and there's often a lot of
misinformation for garbled information
that comes out in the in the in the
immediate aftermath of one of these uh
horrible incidents about but some uh
reports from eyewitnesses indicated that
the shooter may have been using an
automatic weapon
uh there are people obviously wounded
people who uh there have been fatalities
uh we will find out later how how many
uh of the of them there are this is the
first mass shooting incident that I'm
aware of in the United States
in 2023
um and uh as always uh this is the a
very shocking incident and and something
that has stunned people in this uh uh
small community uh east of Los Angeles
yeah Rob we're going to be checking in
with you of course as this story
develops but for now Rob Reynolds
talking to us from Los Angeles well
thank you